es considerada la reforma más progresiva
de la historia de Colombia la tributaria
Calcula recaudar en 2023 unos 4.000
millones de dólares con los que el
gobierno de Gustavo Petro Busca poder
financiar programas sociales para
lograrlo la reforma se ha centrado en
aumentar impuestos a las personas de
altos ingresos se reduce en los
beneficios Fiscales para empresas se
tributa a las bebidas azucaradas y al
sector minero energético con sobretasas
y con la no deducibilidad de regalías y
se aumentarán recursos y esfuerzos en la
lucha contra la ilusión y la evasión
pero durante tres meses de negociaciones
también ha habido renuncias y es que el
plan inicial del gobierno era recaudar
mil millones de dólares más de los
logrados dinero perdido en la no
inclusión de los impuestos a las
iglesias a Ultra procesados como el pan
la leche la miel o las obleas y en
impuestos a pensiones altas
de hecho pasar esta reforma ha sido una
obsesión para el presidente el 8 de
agosto Un día después de la jura de
Posesión se presentó el proyecto con
tres objetivos sociales específicos que
son erradicar el hambre reducir la
pobreza y desmontar los tratamientos
tributarios preferenciales
pero también ha encontrado la oposición
de sectores de las clases privilegiadas
y medias en pleno aumento de la
inflación y con la devaluación de la
moneda esto con distintas protestas y
con el centro democrático principal
partido de oposición asegurando que
demandarán la Reforma por considerar la
inconstitucional
la ocde lleva tiempo insistiendo en la
necesidad de una reforma en Colombia y
dio el visto bueno a la de Gustavo Petro
después de que el Antiguo gobierno de
Iván Duque viviese Las mayores protestas
en décadas cuando trató de impulsar su
reforma tributaria con un carácter más
regresivo e impositivo en las clases
medias y bajas